[Music]
hi my name is Ivan Orkin we're at my
restaurant Ivan ramen on the Lower East
Side and we're gonna talk about scaling
today
scammin in its simplest description is
cold noodles dipped into hot soup ramen
was never served that way until about 30
years ago and it became famous from the
owner of a restaurant called taisho ken
in Tokyo well you know scheming in a way
is sort of deconstructed ramen instead
of having you know a big bowl of
steaming broth and noodles and then a
piece of meat laid on top it's all
broken out so you keep the texture of
the noodle and I like that style a lot
because of that I think it's a it's a
really cool little centric experience so
we serve two kinds of noodles at Ivan
ramen we serve a rye noodle that's thin
and we serve a whole wheat noodle that's
thick I use my whole wheat noodles in
the application of scammin because you
want to be chewing and have that whole
experience of chewing whereas when
you're eating a bowl of hot soup it's
it's a different eating experience the
scam and soup is supposed to be sort of
stronger and saltier and richer than
regular ramen soup because it needs to
stick to the noodles and it needs to
stand up to that noodles that aren't
sitting in the broth scammin drops
generally speaking have a lot of them
you know in Japanese they like to say it
has punch our pork broth is is probably
about 12 to 14 hour broth the classic
sort of Toccata style uses heads and
femurs and it's cooked for 40 hours and
the bones melt we don't go quite that
far we use pork backs we use chicken
feet we use caramelized vegetables and
cook that down to a pretty rich
consistency
the egg has always been my favorite part
of the ramen it's running in the center
and firm on the outside and here we do
spicy collards which really love and
they're very delicious and a big round
of pork Josh its bites of things you
could you pick up some noodles you
dipped them in the broth you slurp them
up take a piece of the pork and maybe
dip it in the soup that you want and eat
that and eat some collards and no matter
how much I warn a guest or advise a
guest a lot of people end up taking the
broth and dumping it on top of their
cold noodles which is sort of like it's
you know like eating pizza with a fork
and a knife
[Music]
so it's very exciting time to be in New
York and in America for for Robin
because it's sort of like Japan 15 20
years ago
scammin is something that people weren't
really comfortable with in Japan
initially and now there's shops all over
Japan that only serves gaming so I'm not
surprised that it's a new thing for
Americans but it's really fun way to eat
it's fun way to dip and slurp for me
personally I mean I've eaten you know
tens of thousands of bowls of ramen and
I eat a bowl of ramen I think of nothing
else but the bowl of ramen I don't talk
to anybody I don't eat my salad I like
get into the bowl and I usually slurp
and chew and suck or whatever until the
ball is empty
[Music]